Payne we know it when we feel it but
pain is frustrating not just because it
hurts but because it's so subjective and
hard to quantify what do doctors rely on
as the gold standard to evaluate pain in
2016
self assessment that's right a chart
that goes from happy face with zero
- sobbing face ten not exactly precise
so why can't we just plug someone into a
machine and get an objective readout of
how much pain they're in pain is
complicated and there's still a lot we
don't know about it
here's what we do know pain is useful
it helps us react quickly if we're in
danger and alerts us to injury and
illness there might even be a good kind
of pain I feel like you know no pain no
gain though saying I mean range true for
like working out and like I guess like
trying to like achieve a goal you know
studying hard for a test popping a six
you have masseuse that's a good pain I'm
like rub that tension away we do mostly
understand the biochemistry of how pain
signals get sent to the brain we can
design drugs that target that chemistry
to ease pain but we haven't found a way
to look at those signals to measure it
some mutations in our genes lead to pain
disorders like not being able to feel
pain or feeling excessive amounts but
more often genes and the environment we
live in both contribute to whether we
experience some sort of pain disease
like arthritis so pain starts out as a
signal registered by sensors in the body
but once the signals get to the brain
our expectations can affect how strongly
we feel that pain rather than simply
passing the signal along our higher
brain functions metal in what we end up
feeling a group of areas in the brain
called the pain matrix will light up in
an MRI scan when an individual is
feeling pain but recent research shows
that the pain matrix can be misleading
using a group of patients who never feel
pain a study found that their pain
matrix still activates in response to
stimuli that healthy people find painful
what the pain matrix actually responds
to is any kind of threat whether it's
painful or not researchers are now
pursuing what they call the neurological
pain signature they're counting on
high-resolution scanning techniques to
show what specific parts of the pain
matrix are involved in feeling actual
pain they also want to learn how the
brain separates immediate pain from
chronic pain
scientists are hoping that someday they
will have a pattern of brain activation
that corresponds exactly to pain our
brains will always make pain a unique
experience for each of us but perhaps in
the future our understanding of pain can
be more precise than sobbing face 10 on
the pain scale where do you think the
worst pain ever falls
I think zero and I but I know I have a
high tolerance for pain and shall burn
without any I've always wondered how
does my sense of pain compared to other
people's sense of pain and that would
kind of if they could say this hurts as
much as breaking my leg